>> ONE OF THE MOST FREEING
THINGS THAT WHITE PEOPLE CAN
DO -- ACTUALLY ANY HUMAN BEING
ON THE PLANET COULD DO RIGHT NOW
IS TO JUST SAY OF COURSE I'M
RACIST.
OF COURSE I'M RACIST.
OUR SOCIETY SPEAKS RACISM.
IT HAS SPOKEN RACISM SINCE WE
WERE BORN.
>> Laura: IT SEEMS THE
PORTLAND KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS
TOOK THAT TO HEART, BECAUSE NEW
TEACHING MATERIALS THAT ARE
OBTAINED EXCLUSIVELY BY CHRIS
RUFO EXPOSE HOW RACE HAS NOW
INFECTED THE ALREADY OBSESSED
CURRICULUM THAT'S INSIDE THE
PORTLAND PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WANT TO SHOW YOU JUST A COUPLE
OF THESE SLIDES.
ONE SUGGESTS THAT EVEN THE WORD
TRANS CAN BE RACIST, AS IT IS
THE LANGUAGE PREFERRED BY THE
COLONIZERS.
INSTEAD THEY RECOMMEND ADDING
SOMETHING CALLED TWO SPIRITS TO
BE EXCLUSIVELY INDIGENOUS.
IF AND IF THAT ISN'T BAD ENOUGH,
ONE OF THEIR SLIDES GLAMORIZE IS
THE ACT OF WRITING AS AN
ACCEPTABLE REACTION TO ANYTHING
PERCEIVED TO BE WHITE
COLONIZATION.
HERE NOW IS CHRIS RUFO,
MANHATTAN'S SENIOR FELLOW.
SO NOW GENDER IS COLONIZED?
AND I DON'T EVEN REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE TRANS THING AT
ALL, I'M NOT FOLLOWING THAT.
BUT WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON
HERE?
KIDS AS YOUNG AS 5?
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING IS PORTLAND
PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE TAKEN
ACADEMIC THEORY AND TURNED IT
INTO A K THROUGH FIVE PEDAGOGY.
THEY ARE TEACHING KIDS THAT SOME
BOYS CAN HAVE VAGINAS, SOME
GIRLS CAN HAVE PENISES, THEY ARE
ENCOURAGING THEM TO ADOPT
IDENTITIES SUCH AS GENDERQUEER,
NONBINARY AND -- THEY ARE
TELLING KIDS THIS IS PART OF A
POLITICAL MOVEMENT.
IT WAS POLITICAL RACE THEORY
LESTER, IT'S QUEER.
THIS YEAR, YOU HAVE TO GET ON
BOARD, RESHAPE YOUR IDENTITY
ACCORDING TO THIS IDEOLOGY AND
THAT BY THE END OF FIFTH GRADE
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THEM READING
OUT COMMITMENTS TO COMMIT THEIR
LIVES RADICAL LEFT-WING ACTIVISM
BY THE AGES OF TEN AND 11 YEARS
OLD.
>> Laura: NOW, IN THIS LIGHT,
THE PORTLAND PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM TRYING TO DEMONIZE THE
IDEA OF GENDER ALTOGETHER,
SAYING THAT GENDER IS SOMETHING
THAT ADULTS CAME UP WITH TO SORT
PEOPLE INTO GROUPS.
NOW, CHRIS, THEY ARE TRYING TO
ERASE THE IDEA OF THE TWO SEXES,
LIKE THIS IS BINARY, COMPLETELY.
THAT'S WAY OUT THE WINDOW.
>> EXACTLY.
THE BEST WAY TO THINK OF THIS IS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY DIVIDES THE
WORLD INTO RACIAL GROUPS AND
SAYING THAT THEY ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY AGAINST EACH
OTHER, OPPRESSING ONE ANOTHER.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO THE SAME
THING WITH SEX, SAYING THAT
WHITE HETEROSEXUAL MEN HAVE
ALWAYS OPPRESSED RACIAL AND
MINORITIES.
IT'S THE SAME KIND OF BASIS
MARXIST THEORY NOW APPLIED TO
BOTH RACE AND GENDER.
IT'S HAPPENING IN PORTLAND, IT'S
HAPPENING ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY
IN RK THROUGH 12 PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
>> Laura: THIS NEXT SLIDE YOU
HAVE OBTAINED I THINK IS THE
MOST DISTURBING, DESCRIBING
GENDER DYSPHORIA.
IT SAYS IF A KID IS STILL
FIGURING OUT THERE -- I LOVE
THAT -- THERE GENDER AND NEEDS
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT BODY PARTS
SHAPES AND EXPRESSIONS THEY
WANT, THEY CAN TAKE HORMONE
BLOCKERS THAT CAUSE PUBERTY --
THAT PAUSE PUBERTY AND GIVE THEM
TIME TO FIGURE OUT WHO THEY ARE.
SO, CHRIS, THEY'RE PUSHING THE
IDEA OF MEDICALLY ALTERING YOUR
BODY ON LITTLE KIDS.
THAT'S -- WHAT COULD GO WRONG
THERE?
>> THESE ARE OUR FOURTH AND
FIFTH GRADERS AND THEY ARE
TELLING THEM THEY CAN START
PUBERTY BLOCKERS.
THEY CAN GET DOUBLE MASTECTOMIES
FOR THE GIRLS.
THEY CAN ADOPT THESE SYNTHETIC
SEXUAL IDENTITY SUCH AS TRANS
AND NONBINARY AND ALL DOING ALL
OF THIS WITHOUT NOTIFYING
PARENTS.
EVERYONE SHOULD BE ON GUARD FOR
THIS IDEOLOGY IN THE SCHOOLS
BECAUSE IT'S COMING.
IT'S COMING TO A SCHOOL NEAR
YOU.
>> Laura: I KNOW PORTLAND IS A
LIBERAL PLACE, BUT DO MOST
PARENTS AND IMMIGRANT PARENTS --
IS THIS WHAT THEY WANT FOR THEIR
KIDS [BOOS]
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT, IT'S
DEEPLY UNPOPULAR.
AND ACTUALLY JUST MINUTES AGO,
AFTER I BROKE THIS STORY, THE
ADMITTED STRAINERS AT PORTLAND
PUBLIC SCHOOLS STARTED FURIOUSLY
DELETING ALL OF THESE DOCUMENTS
FROM THEIR WEBSITES, FROM THE
INTERNET, BECAUSE THEY COULD
ONLY DO THIS IN SECRECY.
THEY CAN ONLY DO THIS HIDING IT
FROM PARENTS, BY HIDING IT FROM
THE PUBLIC.
BUT WHEN WE SHINE A LIGHT ON IT,
WHEN PARENTS SHOW UP AT THOSE
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS AND START
TO MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD,
THESE IDEOLOGIES SHRINK AND
CRUMBLE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T STAND
THE LIGHT OF DAY.
THEY ARE EVIL, THEY'RE HARMING
KIDS, AND PARENTS HAVE TO STAND
UP AND FIGHT BACK TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO MORE LIVES ARE RUINED BY
QUEER THEORY IN THESE HARMFUL
IDEOLOGIES.
>> Laura: NO, BUT REMEMBER,
MERRICK GARLAND IS GOING TO MAKE
SURE ALL THESE PARENTS ARE
CONSIDERED DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS
IF THEY GET A LITTLE HEATED AT
THESE SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS,
WHICH A LOT OF MOMS AND DADS,
WHEN THEY SEE THIS STUFF, THEY
ARE GOING TO GET A LITTLE
HEATED, SO NOW THEY WILL HAVE TO
BE WORRIED ABOUT BEING
CATEGORIZED AS SEMESTER
TERRORISTS.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING WE ARE
DEALING